hello guys congratulations on the movie
thank you Matt my first question is for
you because I am just absolutely
obsessed with Biola Davis and how she
can get the absolute most out of every
ounce of screen time she gets so having
worked opposite her on this what do you
think her Secret Sauce is what did you
see her doing on this set that sets her
apart from other scene Partners you've
had I mean it's it's very tough to
quantify it uh you know I've seen her
I've seen on you know her in movies I've
seen her on stage
uh she's a very explosive actress she's
she can be and what was amazing about
this was how she talked about a
neutrality with Dolores and everything
she saw there's like an opacity Dolores
doesn't give away
you know she like her poker hand you
never know which what card she's holding
and it's it's just the the the amount of
power that Viola can bring doing what
looks like nothing but it's not it's
very very much not nothing
um it's just another it's another
you know Arrow inner quiver in terms of
like how Dynamic her performances are
like this is just another gear she's
just amazing I just met her today and I
just told her what a great job she did
in the movie
and it was I've seen her great in every
movie yeah but for her to find a
different way to be great whereas some
people would give less her less is
actually more it's it's an intent an
intensity behind it was in and it was so
it was I found this performance so
powerful in a way I have never seen her
perform it was like it was like you felt
this power beneath it but it wasn't on
server like doing nothing right if
somebody literally does nothing you'd
lose interest in them right but when
when an actress like Viola I think also
like Meryl street but she didn't do this
a lot like he does it you just for some
reason Brando you said you you're
leaning toward you're coming towards
them you can't you're like what is it
about this person that that I'm you know
there's something there's like an
electricity to them whole damn movie
with her and I took it with me after the
fact too Marlin for you we only get to
spend so much time with George because
it's a big Ensemble piece so I was
wondering if you learned anything about
him while you were prepping for the film
that maybe we don't see or hear about in
the movie but we can feel informing your
performance you know just what a um just
like he himself is a legend you know I
mean you're doing you wouldn't he was
the first black you know coach to win
like a a championship I mean like in in
college sports like that that's huge and
the fact that he was an Olympic Olympic
coach on an Olympic team that Jordan
those guys played on and he just has a a
a
um incredible
um story himself and to be able to play
a legend like him and uh in one scene
which is great because you get to do so
much and you study so much and then you
get to pour it out in this one fantastic
beautifully written scene
um with a a great actors you know it's a
dream another example of a small amount
of screen time that makes a massive
impression and I can't emphasize that
enough I think I'm gonna stop acting I'm
just gonna do extra rolls for now on
that's all because they're so intense do
you see Marlon walking by
oh he was good in that one
before they kicked me out of here man I
wanted to ask one question about artist
Equity because I love what you guys are
doing over there right now and it was
making me wonder what was it about like
what's going on right now that made you
and Ben think like now is the time to
launch this and just so our viewers can
understand it a little better beyond the
idea of fixing the whole you know
back-end participation thing what is
something you'll be able to offer the
filmmakers that you work with during the
development and production process to
give them a more fulfilling experience
than they would with a studio well I
mean for for for the technicians a lot
of them get pulled above the line and so
they they you know we think they've been
woefully underpaid uh historically and
uh so we'd like to see if we can address
that but in terms of the filmmakers it's
it's that you know the directors you
know we're the studio so your studio
notes are going to come from us and and
you're it's it should feel uh you know
we we want it to feel intensely
collaborative and kind and really the
kind of place like we hope that anybody
who works with us won't want to work
anywhere else isn't my kind of
filmmaking Vibe I love it
congratulations on that congratulations
on this I mean it I absolutely adore
this film awesome thank you very much